[Musique]
les américains aiment les héros et le
général dwight eisenhower en état il
était le commandant suprême des forces
alliées en europe
le stratège du département normandie et
de ceux qui l'ont précédé en afrique du
nord et en sicile la prime
bouchon de 12 km par ses exploits ont
précipité l'effondrement du reich nazi
né en 1890 à des naissains texas ce
militaire de carrière c'est écouter
organiser gérer de grands ego comme les
généraux patton montgomery ou de gaulle
économe de la vie de ses soldats il est
respecté et aimé les républicains
parviennent à convaincre de se lancer
dans la course à la présidence de 1952
en fait les honoraires veut absolument
devenir président pour empêcher les
états unis de faire comme ils ont fait à
la fin de la première guerre mondiale de
se retirer finalement la scène
internationale pour plutôt embrasser le
rôle qui est le rôle qu'ils ont adoptées
au cours de la guerre froide est celui
du ce qu'on dit souvent le gendarme
international donc à travers notamment
de l'automne donc c'est ce qui anime
beaucoup la volonté dans un art world se
lance en politique
les populaires on aime son surnom haïk
c'est un chic type louaybi ce n'est les
frères dewaele
on rajoute un peu musique il ne fait
qu'une bouchée de son adversaire rezaï
stevenson record historique de votre
populaire 55% des voix son
vice-président et les knicks qui sera
aussi son gendre les états unis des
années 50 sont prospères heureuse les
baby boomers peuple les banlieues il
7 des voitures et eisenhower leur donne
65 mille kilomètres d'autoroutes le
fameux in to stay away système serait
plus qu'un et progressistes et il
améliore les programmes sociaux du new
deal de franklin roosevelt
politiquement c'est la chasse aux
sorcières aux communistes du sénateur
républicain joseph mccarthy un embarras
pour le président car il s'attaque aussi
à l'armée et à son gouvernement
il hésite à confronter mcafee tombera
fin 1954
tout à coup il hésite aussi face à la
ségrégation raciale dans les écoles à
l'étonnante art 15 as mais il finira par
envoyer l'armée pour y faire accepter
les neuf jeunes noirs ce soldat n'aime
pas la guerre
il met fin à la guerre de corée et
refuse de s'engager au vietnam aux côtés
des français en difficulté ils empêchent
la grande bretagne la france et israël
d'occuper le canal de suez
par contre il n'hésite pas autorisé la
cia renversé le premier ministre iranien
mohammed mossadegh
le président guatémaltèque jacobo arbenz
et à préparer l'invasion de la baie des
cochons pour se débarrasser de fidel
castro
tout ça au nom de la lutte contre le
communisme
vraiment une belle chute collective au
moun ka c'est la guerre froide en 1955
l'urss fait exploser sa bombe h
en joueur de poker alezane avoir
poursuit la course aux armements et
n'hésite pas à bloquer le leader
soviétique nikita khrouchtchev qui
accepte une invitation à visiter des
états unis c'est un bon considérant le
l'inconnu devant lequel on se trouvait à
cette époque donc avec ces tous ces
nouveaux paramètres finalement de
l'opposition entre deux superpuissances
développement de l'arme atomique
je dirais qu'il est noir tout comme son
prédécesseur harry truman comme un fait
un bon travail dans les circonstances
avec en italie de manière ferme contre
les ambitions de l'union soviétique mais
mesurée également en évitant des
confrontations trop directe à la veille
de son départ de la maison blanche
ce grand guerrier surprend tout le monde
en mettant en garde contre une
domination possiblement désastreuse du
complexe militaro industriel
c'est certainement un bon présidence
quelqu'un qui sans doute le président
dont les états unis avaient besoin en
cette période de leur histoire un grand
président je ne sais pas il ya peut-être
pas tant de grans accomplissement qui
ont été accomplis sous son règne
ike a été un président plus tôt oublier
car peu flamboyant un peu terne mais il
a dirigé un pays qui avait besoin de
sécurité et de prospérité